[Music]
shortly after you and your brother were
born
your father and I divorced and we each
took one son obviously haha I got second
pick I have a twin brother my brother
[Music]
final maybe you your discomfort is
Alerian so how are things career-wise
haha great you let the most wanted
village just get away you're fired
Zaza great crashing it I brought you
here to continue the family business the
only is in your blood and broken boobs I
left that life behind me I understand
hmm I wonder what this does
holy moly I'm a villain began
what did you guys do today there's
always a blinder nothing
[Music]
Oh what about that for what Oh girls
I'll make you learn to appreciate me
differentiate we've been waiting a long
time I saw what once was it it was so
fluffy I thought it was no you two are
villains yeah ah I mean hello sweetie Oh
busted
I'm so bad I can see Abby again
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we've been waiting for the breakout
event of the summer
we're going back to villainy this week
only three how could you let Balthazar
brats just get away you're fired
he's really good to snuggle with I miss
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me hey could you oh of course
now as I was saying I goodbye ah
seriously oh I really must have a word
with you on behalf of your twin brother
drew why twin brother my brother
Busey I can't wait to meet my brother
[Music]
doesn't love this color look at him I
love his hair would make you better look
at this face what are you so mad you
must be the beautiful wife oh sweet
talker this place is amazing it's nice
like gas jar I'm not really into things
Mason grew vilnis in blood it grows on
boobs you ready to continue the family
tradition
you and me no I left that life behind me
just one
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
haha okay this does not mean that we are
going back to being so how are things
career-wise they're fired
it's time to get back on top we're going
back to villainy
[Applause]
[Music]
you try to find the feeling of numbness
or get Despicable Me 3
ready PG rock you a pal pal juggernaut
take it up a notch oh my god Wow take a
mile let me take us down
[Music]
Heights music
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
some kind of monster wait that's not a
mobster that's a man wearing shoulder
pads there's only one super villain
whose fashion sense is quite that dated
friend Balthazar flat I want every agent
of the scene immediately in its kursi
are closing fast
kick wait why what did you call us
Brucie
you know GRU and Lucy push together GRU
see aha
I like it but not a lot I don't like it
[Music]
getting away that's what you think
[Music]
get the ready
[Music]
hello haha what about that for what Oh
girls yeah dance fight this is not over
[Music]
[Music]
dear Dan happy birthday who's bad so
brother how are things career-wise
crashing it get your mojo back
we're going back to villainy you two are
villains now ah I mean hello sweetie
Despicable Me 3 ready PG
[Music]